masturbation brakes would be very
effective that work hi I'm Tim and this
is science the show where we find out
what science
what's liance today's topic masturbation
jerking off flogging the dog spanking
the monkey running your hot dog milking
your utter whereas some scientists are
calling it taking a break at the office
according to the New York Post a
psychologist at Nottingham Trent
University believes that masturbation
brakes would be very effective at work
and a great way to relieve tension and
stress a worker who admitted to the
practice told vice jerking off is a
really good way to spend 15 minutes and
it sometimes ended up being the
highlight of my day
note now that we know that you can
masturbate at work the real question is
where no no no no in reality the only
place you should masturbate at work is
already the most pleasurable spot right
here in the can something tells me
that's not a number - anyway until next
time I'm Tim and this is science driven
toilet paper rookie mistake
[Music]